-Our next guest has his comedy
special, "37 & Single,"
streaming now on Netflix.
Please welcome
the very funny Jared Freid!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I was just hanging out
with my parents.
Anyone hang out
with their parents still?
[ Cheers and applause ]
The only problem is
you don't know
if it's going to be a fun hang
or a judgmental hang, right?
My mom will be like,
"Let's have a drink.
Have a drink!
Come on, have a drink!"
And then, the next morning,
I walk into the kitchen.
She's at the table.
It's dimly lit.
She's like, "We have to talk
about the drinking."
You ever been to an intervention
with your own dealer?
Your parents aren't going
to change, though.
Never. My mom is never going
to pronounce Chipotle correctly.
She could be on a game show.
The host would be like,
"For $2 million,
just say Chipotle."
She'd immediately
make herself the victim.
She'd be like,
"Everyone is yelling at me."
The host would be like,
"No one is yelling at you.
For $2 million,
just say Chipotle."
She'd be like,
"This is ridiculous."
Chip-o-tal."
I'm judgy of people's orders,
but people are judgy
of my orders, too.
You know, I went on
a bachelor party in 2016,
and I ordered
a skinny margarita.
That's been my nickname
for seven years.
Every time I hang out
with my friends,
some old lady is like, "Why do
they call you Bethenny Frankel?"
I judge my mom's orders.
She goes to Starbucks.
You ever go to Starbucks
with your mom?
It's a show.
My mom walks in like
she's the lead of a '90s sitcom.
She's like, "Hi, everybody!"
And then she goes up
to a teenage barista
and just screams
coffee ingredients.
They make no sense.
She went up --
Last time we went, she goes,
I'll have an iced mocha,
two-scoop, dolce, frothy top.
You know.
She said, "You know."
That was the craziest part.
The teenage barista
never looked up.
She just goes, "I got it.
She's here every day."
Here's the actual order.
Iced mocha latte with two pumps
of cinnamon-dolce sweetener,
steamed skim milk on top.
"Scoops" are apparently pumps.
That teenage barista is the
greatest detective of our time.
Right? I just imagine
her in her bedroom.
There's, like,
boy-band posters everywhere,
a picture of my mom,
red string out to all the clues.
She's sitting there
with a cigarette.
She's like, "Dolce.
Frothy top."
I want to go on
every errand with my mom.
Not the places that know her,
not the places that
don't know her,
the ones in the middle,
the ones getting to know her.
Right? The place where she walks
in and she's like,
"Hi, everybody,"
and five high-school kids
are like, "Oh, no!"
Right? She goes to the market.
She goes to the deli counter.
She's like,
"Shrimp-chicken thingy."
You see the deli guy.
"Okay, shrimp woman's back.
Here we go.
Remember, shrimp means
salami, 1/4 pound.
She wants it sliced thin,
but not too thin,
but kind of thin.
Chicken thingy --
not a chicken, not a turkey.
We'll go provolone.
We got nothing to lose."
She's just not a communicator,
even over texts.
She texts "LOL" to everything.
"LOL. LOL." I hate LOL.
It's a dishonest acronym.
Everyone texts "LOL,"
but you've never seen someone
with their phone in their hand
just in the middle
of the street, just like...
[ Laughs ]
It's dishonest.
I only send honest texting
acronyms, only honest ones,
like "TITTTITWAWSD."
"This is the third time
I've texted, what's up,
are we still dating?"
"YTACIGAYP."
"Your texts are coming in green,
are you poor?"
"PRMFTGTILTOTCIAKGETTTAFSE."
"Please remove me
from this group text,
I've lost track
of the conversation
and I keep getting excited
thinking the text
is from someone else."
Thank you, guys.
I'm Jared Freid.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Two scoops. Two scoops.
-Yeah.
-The best. Jared Freid!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"37 & Single"
is available now on Netflix.